vous ne savez rien c'est ça ou vous avez
choisi de ne rien savoir
[Musique]
votre mari m'a volé deux millions de
dollars
[Musique]
des sachets de ma fille
il s'agit de ma fille
et puisqu'il s'agit de ma vie maintenant
il s'agit de la vôtre l'accord
il s'est passé quelque chose cette nuit
quelque chose de terrible
monsieur vliegen votre famille faisait
partie de la vie de harry depuis très
longtemps j'ai besoin d'aidé je vois pas
ce que je peux faire
nos maris ne reviendront pas
on met tout
mon mari m'a laissé les plans de son
prochain qu as tu besoin d'une équipe
pour aller jusqu'au bout pourquoi on
devrait faire confiance parce que je
suis votre seul rempart contre une balle
dans la tête
ce que les hommes comme votre mari et
mon père m'ont appris
c'est qu'on récolte ce qu'on sème
espérant leur
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour les flingues mes fringues que
je trouverai où tu trouveras
si ça tourne mal je veux que mes enfants
sachent que je me suis pas laissé faire
j'ai agi
notre meilleur atout c'est d'être qui
nous sommes pourquoi parce que personne
ne s'imagine qu'on va avoir les couilles
d'aller jusqu'au bout